Hi there, my name is Silendrin. I work
with Nvidia on the generative AI
platforms team. In this video, we'll
look at what it takes to build effective
AI agents that always stay relevant and
helpful over time. And it's not about
powering them up with the next biggest
LLM in the market. All they need is
simple data flywheels. In this video, we
look at what data fly wheels are and how
we applied them to an internal agent at
NVIDIA. I'll also share with you the
lessons that we learned along the way.
And most importantly, I'll leave you
with tools and techniques and a
framework to think about how you could
build your own data fly wheels for your
own agent AI use case. Let's get
started. So AI agents are generating a
lot of buzz recently and it's rightfully
so. They're already starting to make
their way into your workforce as new
digital employees. They come in
different forms and sizes depending on
the use case that you apply to. They
exist as customer service agent,
software security agents, research
agents and etc etc. But what really are
agents? If you look at the definition of
agents, you will see agents are systems
that are able to perceive, reason, and
act on the underlying task. That means
they're able to look at data. They're
able to reason and come up with a
reasonable plan to act on the specific
user query and they make use of tools
and functions and external systems to
achieve the underlying task. But in my
opinion, what completes the cycle is if
AI agents are able to capture and learn
from user feedback along the way and
thus learning from that user preferences
and data and constantly refining themsel
to be more accurate and useful for the
underlying
task, right? But we all know building
agents can be very painful and scaling
them can be increasingly challenging for
sure. For once, the data changes
rapidly. If you are an enterprise
customer and you're using an agentic
system for a use case, you constantly
see a new data business intelligence
flowing into your system. And augmenting
that is changing user preferences and
customer needs, right? And if you're
looking to deploy large language models,
bigger, chunkier models to support the
underlying use case, you also see that
your inference cost is going to go high.
So increase increased usage drives
increased
cost. That's exactly where dataf fly
wheels can help. At its core, it starts
with the enterprise data. Data flywheel
is a continuous loop or cycle of data
processing and curation, model
customization, evaluation, and
guardrailing them for safer
interactions, building state-of-the-art
rack pipelines alongside enterprise
data. uh to provide relevant accurate
responses.
So as AI agents run in production
environments, this data flywheel cycle
triggers a continuous cycle of data
curation of ground truth using inference
data, business intelligence, user
feedback to continuously experiment and
evaluate existing and newer models to
surface efficient smaller models that
provide at par accuracy expectations as
that of larger language models but which
offer lower latency, faster inference
and effectively lower cost to uh
ownership, total cost of ownership or
inference
cost. Before we go into how do you build
your data flywheel, here's something
exciting that we announced a few weeks
back at Nvidia. We announced Nemo
microservices. It's an end-to-end
platform to build powerful agentic and
generative AI systems
um and also powerful data flywheels
around them. It it's a model micros
service that has various components for
each stage of this data wheel loop.
There's Nemo curator that helps with
curating high quality training data set
including multimodal data. Nemo
customizer helps with fine-tuning and
customizing underlying models using
state-of-the-art um customization
techniques like LoRa Ptuning full SFT
and we're continuously adding more
fine-tuning capabilities. Nemo evaluator
to evaluate um benchmark on academic
benchmarks, institutional benchmarks uh
as well as using LM as a judge. Nemo
guardrails for providing guardrail
interactions for privacy, security, and
safety. And Nemo retriever to build
state-of-the-art rack pipelines. And the
best part about this Nemo microservices
is the ease of use. They're exposed as
simple to use API endpoints. And with
just a single or few API calls, you're
able to customize large language models,
evaluate them, guard rail them for the
underlying use case. And you also have
the flexibility to run these
microservices anywhere on prem on cloud
on data center even on the edge. And
with NV support you get the enterpriseg
grade stability and support as
well. Now here is a sample data flywheel
architecture leveraging Nemo
microservices. I like to think of it as
Lego pieces where I can just put
together these Nemo microservices
components to build this entire data
flywheel setup. So in this sample
architecture you can look at the end
user who's interacting with the front
end of an agent. Think of it maybe say a
customer service agent. It's guardrail
for safer interactions behind the scenes
and uh on the back end there is an model
that is served as an Nvidia NIM for
optimized inference.
So to figure out what's the right model
to power this use case without
compromising on accuracy, you can set up
a data flywheel loop to constantly
curate the data, store it in Nemo data
store uh and use Nemo customizer and
evaluator to trigger a continuous cycle
of retraining and evaluating and once
you see a certain model meet the target
accuracy, you can use your your IT admin
or an AI engineer can promote this model
uh to power uh the agentic use case as
the NVDN underlying this. So that's a
sample
architecture. Let's take a look at a
real world case study on how we adopted
and built this data flywheel for our NV
info agent for an internal employee
support agent that helps Nvidia
employees with access to enterprise
knowledge across multiple domains. It's
a customer service or an employee
support chatbot
agent can help answer queries across a
variety of domains from HR benefits,
financial earnings, IT help, product
documentation or anything everything
that an internal employee needs access
to. So here's a quick look at the
underlying data wheel architecture that
we built for this particular agent.
Just like we saw a user in this case an
employee when they submit a query to
this particular agent uh it's guardrail
for safety and u secure interaction and
underneath uh this most important router
agent which is run by an LLM um is
orchestrated by multiple expert agents
underneath. So each of these agents do a
great job in their individual specific
domain and they're augmented with you
know a a rack pipeline to fetch the
relevant information to answer the user
query effectively. So in order to decide
what models to use and power each of
these green models that you see, we have
a data fly loop set up uh which
constantly builds on top of the user
feedback and production data inference
log that come in when this router is in
action. So using a subject matter expert
and human the loop feedback the ground
truth is continuously curated. Nemo
customizer and evaluator are used to
constantly evaluate multiple models to
promote the most effective model as a
nymph to power this router
agent. And the if you're curious to know
what these red ones are since this is a
multimodel agentic system. The red ones
are essentially everything that could go
wrong uh with with this multimodel
agentic system. But um for the sake of
this exercise and understanding a
concept in detail, let's look at one of
these in in in u further detail. Let's
look at the router agent since we've
been spending some time talking about
it. So it's it's basically orchestrated
by a mixture of agent architecture
underneath. So the router agent
depending on the user query understands
the intent and context and guides or
routes the query to one of these expert
agents which further uses the rack
pipeline underneath to fetch the
relevant information.
So the problem statement is given a user
query which of the agents the expert
agents should the router route the query
to uh and the goal here is to ensure
that our agent the routing agents uh
accurately routes it to the correct
export agent uh but
also using faster and cost effective LLM
to achieve this
task. So to start off, we compared and
contrasted a variety of models to power
this router agent. When we used a 3.170B
or 3.370B variants, we noticed a 96%
baseline accuracy. That is just
deploying the foundational pre-trained
model Aziz without any u fine-tuning or
any actions on that. And we noticed that
the baseline accuracy was 96% in terms
of routing the query to the right expert
agent. But if you see the smaller
variants, the accuracy is subpar. The 8b
variant is below 14%. And that's not
ideal for our use case. And that's
exactly where most of the enterprise
evaluations get it wrong. So they see a
bigger model uh deliver state-of-the-art
amazing accuracy of 96% and there's a
smaller model that gives you low
accuracy and they figured that out. Hey,
we need to go with uh a 70B variant
because we're seeing a 96 to a 14%
comparison. I don't think even with
fine-tuning we would be able to get
there. But that's exactly where data fly
wheels kind of help you. So what we did
was we ran the 70B um llama variant and
uh we used and circulated a feedback
form among Nvidia employees and we asked
them to submit few we asked employees to
submit few queries and capture uh the
feedback in terms of whether the the
response was useful to them or not. uh
based on that we were able to curate
around,224 data points. 729 of them were
incorrect sorry satisfactory responses
and 495 of them were unsatisfactory
responses. There was something wrong
that our employees were not happy
with. So here's what we did. We used
Nema evaluator and use LLM as a judge to
investigate this 495 unsatisfactory
responses. We figured out that 140 of
them uh were due to incorrect routing
and using a subject matter expert and
further manual analysis we found out 32
of them were truly due to this incorrect
routing. So we figured out and set up a
ground trth data point data set of 8 68
85 data points and we split them into
6040 to train or fine-tune smaller
models and 40 to test and evaluate uh
the
accuracy. So you will be surprised to
know just with 685 data points the
results that we achieved were
outstanding and this was possible only
because of the data flywheel setup.
So the 70B variant like we saw provided
us gave us an accuracy of 96%
uh for accurately routing it to the
right export agent but it came with an
latency of 26 seconds
uh to to generate the first token
response whereas the 8b variant gave us
an accuracy of 14% but the latency was
almost 78 u 70% uh
lower. So on further fine-tuning various
variants like the 8B and 3B models, we
observed that the 8B with a bit of
finetuning was able to match the
accuracy of a 70B variant and uh
depending on how critical the mission
critical your use case is. Uh you can
even look at the 1B variant. It's got a
94% accuracy. That's not bad. Uh it's
just 2% below 70B. So like I said, you
can take uh a trade-off between how
accurate you want your agent to be
versus the cost that you want to manage
and the resource that you want resource
that you want to manage underneath. So
by deploying let's say a 1B model,
you're looking at a 98% savings in terms
of lower inference cost and
also 10x 70x model size reduction with
70x lower latency. So that's the magic
of data fly and imagine building an
automated loop or a cycle of continuous
and periodic evaluation and fine-tuning
as newer models are published into
market and uh effectively surfacing
smaller models that can run your agentic
workflow to replace larger models that
you already had in production.
continuously learning from uh the
ongoing production log and knowledge uh
and using that to train smaller models
is is the power of data fly wheel. So as
next steps I hope you will explore Nemo
microservices and NVIDIA NIM to build
your next agentic use case and also the
data fly wheel. But here's a good
framework to think about how do you
build effective data flywheels?
So the first step starts with monitoring
user feedback. Start thinking about
intuitive ways to collect user feedback
signals, right? Intuitive user
experience, privacy compliance, implicit
signals, and even explicit signals to
understand whether the models that are
powering your agentic system is going
through model drift or uh any
inaccuracies. and spend time analyzing
and attributing the errors or model
drift that you see as to why the agent
is behaving a certain way. Classify
those errors, attribute those failures,
create that ground truth data set that
can be further used for the third and
fourth step of plan and execute.
The planning is where you identify
different models, generating synthetic
data sets, experimenting with them,
fine-tuning them, and understanding and
optimizing your resource and cost and uh
putting them into action by executing
it. Execution does not just mean
triggering a data flywheel
cycle, but also setting up a regular
cadence or a mechanism to track your
accuracy, latency,
um monitoring, uh performance and
production logs and and truly managing
your end toend geni ops pipeline.
So that's a good framework to think
about building data flywheels and hope
um this was super helpful for you to get
started with building your own data fly
wheels for your agentic use
case. So that's all I have for you in
this video. Hope this was informative
and you start thinking about building
not just agentic use cases but also data
fly wheels around them and hopefully
with NVDIA tools and frameworks. Thank
you. Have a wonderful day.